We love to feel close to our pets.
We snuggle them.
We let them lick our faces.
I think the question is being asked,
why not share a meal, maybe a Fancy Feast?
So New York Post just reported
that Purina released their Fancy Feast
petite cat food and Fancy Feast cookbook for humans.
So you can dine with your feline.
And recipes include salmon cappelletti
in a cream and spinach sauce.
Oh, you have me with cream and spinach,
which can be paired with the cat flavored salmon entree
for your kitty in the spinach and a cream gravy.
Oh-hmm.
(laughter)
And Ross, I just thought immediately.
I just wanna be very clear.
So they're teaching you that you can cook meals that sort
of pair nicely with what your cat will be eating, right?
Mimic, pair, yeah.
Yes,
which I think, you know, okay.
I kind of would pair a dinner with my doggies kibble.
Really?
Yeah.
I actually do this, when the eggs are like
just about out, you know, if I have leftover eggs,
I'll scramble my dogs some eggs in the morning
with my omelet.
Absolutely.
So I guess I was judging them, but I do this already.
So go for it, I'm not gonna be catty.
Lots of pet owners do some chicken, rice, eggs
for their pets.
And a lot of people's pets are their families.
So listen, my favorite phrase, live and let live, man!
You wanna make a cat adjacent dinner, adjacent to your cat
and sit there and talk about the similarities,
you do you.
And you know, you could do breakfast, lunch, dinner,
even a late night snack.
We all love a late night snack,
but Real Simple says, "Dermatologist warn,"
Drew, "it could be bad for you."
More specifically, bad for your skin.
Eating before bed weakens an enzyme
that protects skin from UV damage.
Drew's so bummed right now.
Experts say, give yourself two hours to digest
before you go to bed, all right?
And go with organic food like fruits and leafy veggies
and whole wheat bread.
Who wants that?
I was just gonna say.
Late at night.
If at 11 o'clock, you're the person that says,
you know what sounds good right now, kale.
I don't wanna know you.
(laughter)
They say that you should avoid things like chocolate,
fried foods, which is all I ever want.
Here's a true story though.
You know, I'm on this health journey and I'm a snacker.
It's my go-to.
But I want to give you this little tip, okay?
Every night I used to do like a snack of like,
you know, can of Pringles or something.
We've been there, right?
I know.
So I want salty things.
So every night I do the same snack.
I take a pickle and I slice it up and I take some
Parmesan cheese, which is like the lowest
of the calorie cheeses.
And there's no calories, really, in pickles.
And I have my salty snack every night.
And Drew, I walked across the street to the store
and bought you some Parmesan and pickles before
the show today, just so I could show you.
So this is a way you can still have that salty snack
at the end of the night-
Oh!
But not feel guilty.
By the way, this is so good.
All right, you keep snacking and I'll keep talking.
You know, I'm getting married, right?
(cheers and applause)
And I just started planning the wedding.
Who knows how to plan a wedding?
I don't.
Some people start planning though, really early.
Brides reports, "More people are considering
booking a wedding venue even before they're engaged."
Because of 2020, many weddings
have been canceled, postponed, rescheduled,
rescheduled again, the venues are filling up.
But experts say you should probably wait
until you're like engaged to tackle that logistical mountain
and make sure you guys are on the same page together.
I have one thing to say to that.
(mimics tires screeching and motor revving)
No, no, no, no, no.
And by the way, I will say one thing.
I'm not an expert.
Please don't do this.
I think let's just call it,
it's a little crazy.
It's a little crazy.
Don't skip that whole part
of getting engaged before you book the venue.
How about that?
I think it's a very risky thing to do.
Coocoo. (laughs)
(upbeat music)